Mona dune Jaya simi's bakery gets going
early the 34 year old has her hands full
she's busy making a special cake for a
special occasion a big traditional
Nigerian wedding her business is doing
well she's selling plenty of her unique
cakes as the year comes to an end it's a
chance for moolah dune to build up her
business if I have more money Oh get
expand that bakery where I can do bread
where people can walk in big fresh bread
big fresh pastries drew all sorts of
cakes mullah Doon is a trained
pharmacists but she gave up that career
because she loves baking and it brings
in more money as well when she lived
abroad she learned how to make lots of
different kinds of cake
Mulla doings on her way to the bank in
Nigeria's capital Abuja it's hard to get
the money to expand a bakery mullah
dooms trying to get a loan to help her
out
place it up well I'm gets me to find out
about obtaining a loom for my business
I'm how much exactly are you looking at
it will of fighting what exactly that's
about twenty three thousand euros
melittin explains her business model to
the bank manager he needs to see that
she has a realistic plan for how to
spend the money okay by the end it seems
Mullen has one bank manager Roger nOCA
over
he says he'll give her confirmation in
the coming days okay I appreciate your
coming
thank you very what sir and we hope to
eat your bread very soon yes right thank
you
however it's also become clear to mala
Doon that the three to four percent
interest rate on the loan will be
difficult to finance the interest rate
is just too high because at the end of
the day the bank will probably take
everything that you've worked for
because by the time your service balloon
all the profits you make old go to the
bank I'm not I'm not certain I can take
that one
the next day she's back working on the
wedding cake the attention to detail and
love of design make Mullins cakes stand
out from the rest
these are skills she's developed over
time
a wedding cake like this one costs about
a hundred and thirty euros that's enough
for mullah Doon to hire three employees
she makes roughly 20 cakes every week
the multiple dogs in the valuating cake
apart from the beauty is the structure
to avoid accidents and problems I know
weddings are like speciality for
somebody so if you if you mess up that
cake is I do that you're messed up daddy
it's very important that you get your
trays and you know what you're doing
unemployment is high in Nigeria at about
20% in the cities everyone's looking for
work so policy is the coordinator of the
you win program the government
initiative looks to support young
entrepreneurs and help them out once
they've started a new business
the part of the major reasons for
establishing the UN program is also job
creation and the overall objective is to
get between 80 and 110,000 jobs over the
three cycles of the UN program mala Doon
doesn't have much time left
she's been working on the cake for two
days it needs to be ready by tomorrow in
time for the wedding everything has to
be perfect to make sure it's right for
the occasion
finally it's done and delivered before
the guests arrived colorful creations
like this one are becoming more and more
popular at Nigerian weddings but without
credit Mullen says the income isn't
enough to expand the business the way
she wants to she's been relying on
financial help from her family up until
now she's proud of the wedding cake and
it seems the bride's happy with her work
as well bride and groom the colors it's
fantastic wonderful thank you but formal
adun the biggest celebration is waiting
at home it's her youngest son Tammy's
birthday she's made a special cake as
well his very own personalized birthday
cake mola Doon says sharing these
special moments with her children gives
her strength and her drive to become an
independent businesswoman the
confectioner from Abuja is still
dreaming of building up her cake
business
I'll be back there to you and make a
wish I'm dealt